thank you very much very much like
mother ministers um I'm here very
pleased to see that we've managed to
open one chapter again in the accession
negotiations with with Serbia this will
move the country further in the
accession process towards joining the
European Union as a full member
we thank the efforts of the of the
Finnish presidency we know that it it
wasn't easy all along but at the end you
have managed to conclude this result
this is very important and this is very
important also for the new commission
the new commission is fully committed to
the new perspective for all of the
Western Balkans I will work as my
personal priority for the enlargement of
the Western Balkans and we hope to have
at least one of these countries ready to
join at the end of our term at the end
of this term of the Commission this
would bring tangible benefits not only
for Serbia but for the people of Serbia
in short term this is my this is my main
goal today the outcome of the inter
governmental conference is a very
positive signal not only for Serbia but
for the whole region it shows that the
enlargement policy and the integration
process of the of the bar of the Western
Balkans is an important strategic
objective of the EU not only the
Commission but also of the Member States
this is a very important development
that we need to remark we have been able
to open the chapter on the free movement
of
capital because we have seen that there
is progress in the reforms in Serbia we
consider the free movement of capital to
be a backbone of EU membership it's part
of the four freedoms the funding
freedoms of the internal market without
which it is impossible to become a
member we have seen that Serbia has made
significant progress on the free
movement of capital on secured payment
systems prevention of money laundering
or a healthy and attractive business
environment but of course work still
needs to be done and we are here to help
Serbia to conclude on that work very
quickly and hopefully to move ahead to
two other chapters already already next
year the free movement of capital is
also prerequisite for any increase in
foreign direct investment for Serbia so
we will encourage Serbia to engage or
and more in this area as one of the key
objectives of the next Commission is to
bring the Western Balkans closer to
Europe closer in everyday life
closer in economic development and
closer in integrating into the European
Union this makes it even more important
that Serbia continues with the reform
agenda and as a negotiating country one
of the frontrunners it should also set
an example to other countries in the in
the region we think that there's still
quite a bit of work to do but we're
hopeful and we're encouraged by today's
development that this work will bring
results we will try to speed up and
minimize the process as I have explained
that the General Affairs Council today
and the Commission stands ready to work
as much as as it is necessary and it
will start very quickly already in
January to speed up things and dynamize
the accession process thank you we are
ready to take questions please identify
yourself and your media and also to whom
you address your quest start